[Music]
let's talk about it this is a different
kind of superhero story to tell it right
we got to take you back before I
squeezed into red spandex how was it to
be on set it's hard I'm training a lot
and I am naturally not one to gym so
it's been that's been a learning
experience but also honestly it's
amazing kind of watching Ryan do his
thing he's genuinely incredibly talented
and it's like pretty impressive to watch
look at me I know look at it no I don't
want to exactly it's just really good
and so that's been it for me this would
be like the biggest thing I've done so
I've been very much sort of like
observing and it's it's been a good like
good vibe set to observe on and like a
lot of really talented people yeah and
of course all of that is wonderful you
guys did also have a very tragic thing
happened on set how did you handle that
and come together as a set as a cast it
really rocked our boat and still is it
changed a lot and our production changed
a lot in the film that week we shut down
production for a few days and then we
came together and it actually really did
bring the cast sort of to the same place
and we we had a memorial for her and
yeah it was very
sad oh yeah and it was very strange
strange time and still it's like it's
still staying with us and yeah so and
for the stunt community - they are like
I I don't know I just want to say like
we're really proud of our son team and
they're a fantastic team and I just
really sorry really want people to know
like that wasn't supposed to happen and
they're a really good team you forget
that there are people behind the scenes
doing things such an important work and
they just mean a lot so it's been yet I
mean but is we've also like come
together for it and like so but I'm just
like I'm proud of our crew and you know
I I pray for Joy's family and you know
she was a domino and so I feel like kind
of connected to her in that way and you
know and you know the first black like
professional motorcyclist and so yeah so
she lives with us and she I think she
will in the film and yeah
you
[Music]